منذ اندلاع الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه قبل
80 يوما اصبحت المساعدات الاغاثه بمثابه
الشريان الوحيد الذي يساعد سكان غزه على
البقاء على قيد الحياه لكن ما هو حجم
المساعدات التي تدخل الى القطاع المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه قال ان ما يدخل
الى القطاع من مساعدات لا يلبي 2% من
احتياجاته التي تستدعي دخول نحو 1000
شاحنه يوميا لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه لكن
المكتب حذر المؤسسات والهيئات والمنظمات
الدوليه مما وصفه بالتواطؤ في تمرير سياسه
التجويع والتعطيش بحق الفلسطينيين ومن
انتشار المجاعه في محافظات القطاع وطلبها
بالقيام بدورها المطلوب بشكل فاعل وحقيقي
في اخر تقرير له قال برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي ان جميع سكان القطاع يعانون من
ازمه غذاء ومعيشه حاده وان غزه توا جوعا
كارثيا وحذر من خطر حدوث مجاعه في القطاع
اما وكاله الاونر قالت ان نحو 90% من سكان
قطاع غزه اصبحوا نازحين داخليا اي نحو
مليون و900 ال شخص من اجمالي مليونين و300
الف هم عدد سكان
القطاع لكن كيف يبدو وضع الناس في هذه
الظروف مع تفاقم ازمه الغذاء دعونا نرى
هذا المشهد هافه النازحين للحصول على طعام
في احد مراكز الاواء
[تصفيق]
بالقطاع
اما منظمه اليونيسيف التابعه للامم
المتحده فقالت ان اكثر من 80% من اطفال
غزه يعانون من فقر غذائي حاد وان نحو
335 الف طفل تحت سن الخامسه معرضون لخطر
سوء التغذيه الحاد والوفاه مع تزايد خطر
المجاعه احدى النازحات في مخيم جباليا
تحدثت للجزيره عن الظروف الصعبه التي
تعانيها الامهات مع اطفالهن في المخيم
منعاني والله مش من حرب واحد من عده حروب
من الميه حرب قله الاكل حرب قله العلاج
حرب قله المكان كمان فيش مكان نقعد فيه
يعني احنا عارف يمكن اربع او خمس اماكن
تنقلنا من مدرسه لمدرسه لمكان لمكان ما
لقينا هذا المكان ومش امن كمان يعني فيش
امان ولا في اي مكان امان طبخنا رز على
ميه والحمد لله انه نحنا بلاقيه يعني لما
راح ابني يمكن قاعد ثلاث ساعات لما جاب
كيلو الرز لما لاقاه في الدكان في تكين بس
يعني من مكان لمكان بلقاه والحمد لله بس
نضلنا على
هيك اذا هو قاسي الوضع كيف علقتم على هذا
الوضع الانساني المتفاقم داخل القطاع في
ظل شح المساعدات
التي تصل اليه دعونا نبدا هنا بشهن اذا
تقول شهنده المساعدات اللي داخله بالقطاره
ما تكفي قطاع غزه بالكامل الشاحنات مكدسه
على المعبر بتكفي اهل غزه كلهم نصل الى
معتصم يقول معتصم هنا في مدرسه نازحين
بمخيم جباليه لا شيء ياكلوه في المدرسه
الدبابات والقناصه تقتل كل من يتحرك
بالخارج والمخيم فارغ من المخزون الغذائي
الجوع والعطش ينهش امعاء الاطفال اال نصل
ايضا الى ساجده تقول المجاعه انتشرت ما في
اكل ما في مي الامراض انتشرت والوضع كارثه
وعم يزيد سوء لا تتعايش مع الحرب والاخبار
لا توقفوا حكي نصل ايضا الى اسامه هذه
ليست حرب المجاعه الجماعيه ليست حربا قصف
المستشفيات ليست حربا محو الاحياء باكملها
ليست حربا هذه جريمه لقتل جماعيه هذه
اباده لاكثر من ملي مليون شخص اخيرا نصل
الى مشير يقول لا تتركوا غزه وحدها الناس
في غزه تتضور من الجوع والبرد والعطش كل
جهد انساني هو واجب الان لكن الاهم ان
نضغط بكل قوه لتتحرك بادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى غزه سفيره النوايا الحسنه
لدى مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في الامم
المتحده لنحو 20 عاما انجلينا جولي كانت
انتقدت في وقت سابق حرمان اهالي غزه من
الغذاء والدواء والمساعدات الانسانيه
لكنها مؤخرا عبرت عن صدمتها من التناقض
العالمي تجاه معايير حقوق
الانسان
human for these people may sometimes
for these people never for these people
it's food aid 6% for these people 50%
for these
people it's justice for these people but
not these people accountability for this
crime but not that crime if there's
business
interest and this is tru the ugly state
so much of the world y